honey don't we gonna have a good time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna
chose did you get let it fade we got a
spark a little rise let away I'm
counting down and do a starter and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then we're gonna have a good time
a dozen hands up to the sky we gonna
chose did you kill it babe we got a
sparkly
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's a brave day and
we I'm so musical I mean it's musical
morning show that now appropriately has
a song if you haven't stream toast yet
I'm sorry for your loss I can't even
believe person there's someone moving
furniture yeah I can't even believe
there's so many things I can't believe
one I can't believe how big my thigh
looks Wow I'd literally just looked at
the knee you look a Tanner than me first
someone who's been on the heat well I
did the San Tropez mousse and that's is
the strap from my shoe oh yeah
the mousse is good it cuts out on the
street okay I won't point out my flaws
um last night was like actually the best
night of my life and you know when I was
in the car on the way there I was like
very nervous like more nervous and I get
like for a show I don't know why I just
like I didn't I didn't want the song to
like flop or like the party to be weird
I always have a pit when throwing a
party you know there's actually nothing
more treacherous than throwing a party
and we somehow find ourselves like
always throwing random well this just
like celebrating like a small bottle
yeah but we have like major miles yeah
we don't celebrate then we celebrate
these small things but it was really
it's funny how you like categorize a
party like when we had our toast
anniversary was a soiree this was a
partay it was a partay Margo but comes
before Part B
partay yeah Part A Part A what did you
say well what comes before Part B like
just I don't know a popsicle stick it's
from the first ever episode of the hills
I think we're gonna say friends and I
was Oh Heidi it's like what comes before
Part Bay and Lauren's like part a you
know the gang is back together Jackie
French temper is gone
French camper fell off a cliff and
American campers back rose from the dead
we're very excited to be back I'm so
excited to be back I had a wonderful
vacation like much needed but it really
made me miss and love my job and I also
happen to be reading Howard Stern's book
while I was on vacation it was so long
it took me like the whole time and it
just made me really jazzed about what
we're doing here Oh interesting it just
gave me like a new breathe new life in
rated sense of self so I just really
wanted to get back to work and I needed
to come to your launch party so I came
back a few days early to do it all and
like their last night where was the
place called the drug store the drug
store was the place to be yeah by the
way it really was cuz I'm like it was so
loose with invitations list like I
literally invited everyone I know and I
told them I'm like bring five people and
everyone followed the rules like
everyone brought three there were so
many people there that I didn't know no
I didn't know anyone but like I was just
looking around I'm like this is my
[ __ ] party yeah so if you don't know
then like that's not right whatever I
think really everyone added to the vibes
that were what a Dini it's just like you
know I was tapping into you know the
most elite group of toasters like people
so I invited Emily Jenna not oh she came
and she like stuck around the whole time
she was so cool and she had like two
pretty friends she brought with her was
it hard for you to have another model in
the room I mean it's nice to talk to
someone who like understands the
industry guys the craziest thing
happened like when my intern my office
actually since change but for a while my
Instagram bio just said model and when
Olivia Jade and Bella like came back on
Instagram to wish their mama happy
birthday like it was apparently news and
what oh it wasn't Inquisitor yeah it was
Sam like podunk some outlet wrote it up
and they like noted that I left to
comment on it and they refer to me as
model Claudia ASHRAE like they did no
work model pop star comedian she does it
all she does it all mother mother was
the most bloggers the most important
role yeah a woman can play is herself
his mom yeah so yeah everyone just
showed up Emily to Donato Margaret
Josef's came who i absolutely adore her
but she also brought her husband and I
just like I wonder if you had fun he
seemed like he was having a bath I
realized I hadn't met him before but I
feel like I know him jumps off the
screen
you know no totally your husband's in
the pool I really loved them she was
best and then like just out of nowhere I
invited her but I don't think she would
come dr. Sherin easy icon also the life
of the party totally and her date was
her nurse who did my surgery yeah he
like him knows I was so crazy like
scream we have to talk my luck I don't
think I had met him before but like he's
responsible for like the disappearance
of mr. cosmopolitan right no he is truly
like a leading
doctor in his field yeah I Trailblazer
Trailblazer a pioneer um you it was
literally you weren't even being Megan
Fox in Confessions of a Teenage Drama
Queen once to all shows up to her party
but like you could have been that's what
I was gonna say like sue wolf 7 you're
like walking through like Shep rose yeah
and then the entire well not the entire
Naomi left for st. Bart's super early
but like most of the cast came okay and
I just had like a lot of thoughts on
everyone you know I have a lot of
thoughts on everyone because I yesterday
when I got home I caught up on the two
new episodes of southern charm that I
missed so I was like in it and then they
all showed up to the party and I was
like Madison you go girl I like honestly
like Madison is so pretty she's a
precious gem and when I asked her and
also today were gathered like we're not
not together so I think that's yeah
I think they're together based on like
everything that they were doing I think
they should be her dress was so cute
she's so cute Kathryn looked amazing oh
my god she wore the Taylor Swift wretch
her feet dress but she also parted her
hair down the middle but she hasn't done
in a really long time and it looked
really good it looks really good thank
God you didn't wear that dress oh my god
yes I was going to yeah a wafer god that
was trying to convince me to wear the
dress a dress that's like your Tiffany
Haddish dress yes where you just wear it
to everything that is my Tiffany because
you spent money on it and it looks good
on you
I saw banana twice because it's new
dress it's a magical dress - it's like
so sort of it like it fits everyone yeah
no I've never seen someone wear that
dress and look bad and any time I've
seen someone wear that dress like I just
don't Lynn and Sayla warrant I saw Kyle
Richards word on watch happens live any
time I see someone wearing it to me it's
the best they've ever looked or like
they've looked in a long time yeah you
know what I mean I don't know why but I
feel like I wouldn't look at me - I
think really because I feel like the way
that it cuts you like I feel like I
would just look like a big breasted
woman you should try and short I should
try it they sell yeah they sell it at um
sack so you could just go and try it on
okay nothing I can't say the words just
trying on without pretending pretending
to be Penelope Cruz in Spanglish right
didn't I joke I have with my friends so
I was like it's it's a joke
with my right started to say that I'm
like oh no that's a midgets thing no no
it's it's totally tritone just that's
and when she's like sewing the labels
for the daughter it's so cute now who's
so funny it's actually speaking it's
just a really underrated movie yeah okay
who else is at the party I mean Jackie I
was there Jackie I was their
presentation
hopped off the plane at JFK I'm totally
she's seat so long
joey camasta was there he's so fun and
he was he stayed out with us to the
break of dawn yeah so funny like of
course I can't just have a party like I
had to go to the break of dawn of course
it was a big night it was and then when
we went to a club afterwards and Margo
you've been daydreaming about this night
for a long time she was trying to get
him to play and the guy was like super
old like just not even aware of like
anything and she literally was fighting
with him he would've play I like went up
to him and I just played it on my phone
and I was just like here and he's like
oh so it was closing time like there was
nobody there he really could have played
it but like he'll learn you know when
it's like when he's looking cruising the
pop charts for his next song and then he
starts playing toast by Claudia
literally top 10 overall and we're
number 4 on the pop chart I am above you
need to calm down
tell us what I've done I just can't I
mean it it's a better song I actually
would agree what are you thinking your
shirt her supporting the rival Oh Marga
you don't even support me she's
supporting your commutation asking the
song is on iTunes and Spotify believe
it's on Amazon music YouTube music like
all the places any like normal place you
can stream music including title which
is exciting yes and I went on my fire
stick today and I said Alexa Plato's by
Claudia ASHRAE and she said sure fine no
she did she said can't find toast by
Claudia Australia great Pat's Arnie
yeah Claudia Australia Oh somebody left
over pop sockets um maybe I'll just like
do a giveaway because I don't need that
many pop sockets with my face on it no
and like the pop sockets that we sell
are so quality you really don't need to
get a new one I think we should sell
like as business people we should sell
shittier pop sockets keep reaching but
we wouldn't do that you know we sell
bread name yeah um
only the best only the best I'm just
like chilli on a high like when we went
to bed and the song had like made it
into the like 80th the spot on the chart
I was like yes this is really what I set
out to do I just wants like break the
chart get in and then like move on with
my life and then I woke up this morning
and someone sent me that at one point in
time it was number seven overall and I
was like I was ship and a lot of that
just has to do with the fact I think
people are really shocked like the songs
like good no I think everything today is
like just your fans supporting
you ride or die no matter what it sounds
like but it's such a good song that it's
just gonna continue like they're gonna
tell their friends who aren't toasters
and all of a sudden to toast to the Wild
Ones it's like a good son you don't be a
toaster to appreciate it but the
toasters do appreciate it I'll hide you
present like you could have released a
pile of dog sheeting you would have
gotten on the charts right but it's not
that yeah ariana grande's like really
make it difficult for me to secure that
number1 spot but it's ok it's like if
it's gonna be anyone it's either her
Taylor yeah and that's ok and we'll das
lately so it's gonna make it tougher
yeah I don't think I could ever really
get higher than 4 because of those
people Old Town Road ariana grande Liz
Oh
than me yeah ok I mean that's a great
place to be right it is I mean such
great company I'm feeling so comfortable
where I am like I'm just I'm really
excited like you know what like when you
get really excited about something and
then it happens and it's just like it
was like it's like a weird feeling yeah
I'm like I'm acting yeah I am cruising
this high like all the way through the
weekend
no same I mean it's a perfect song I
guess that's why the it I mean music is
on Friday because it's the perfect song
for the weekend preview like I didn't
daydream about this night for a long
time all I want to do is dance with you
under moonlight what could be better so
I posted the the chart I'm a Instagram
and people are accusing me of
photoshopping it that's crazy
I think they could just go look for
themselves like how lazy are you well to
make an accusation before you check they
know what that is that does sound like
something I would do yeah but you
wouldn't Photoshop yourself at number
four you know I would look myself number
one yeah duh dad yeah even if you don't
hit number one you should do that
although some kids like really looks
good they did oh another update for my
party did you see that tellest record
Stephen McGee made up oh no yep they
have been in a fight for like almost a
year I mean it's hard when you're
jamming along to songs as a toast to you
and I to not look at the part next you I
just want to toast to them right
I do you like your words are in just
bringing people together by the way it's
so true that's that's really the power
of music and power of the toast it's so
act it's just it's a great day it's
gonna be a great weekend I literally all
I do is listen to my own song and I
played it in the car yesterday I'm Margo
I dropped you off in anywhere and it was
like are you a singer like yes I you are
good you were a singer before this of
course but now it's too many years oh
nothing singer
yes so Spotify iTunes it's called toe
stick us really truly so much for the
support that's fire this is way more
than I expected and I'm very grateful
and I'm just I'm excited to be alive but
you go to a party so I can play my song
yeah but I don't leave my house so hard
okay well do you think that it's time oh
yeah it's definitely time it feels like
timing you know we'll just go in and out
of course of the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
but before we do that it would be
absolutely remiss heartbroken and
devastated you would be remiss as hell
honestly let me say yes if I didn't let
you guys know that today's episode is
brought to you by daily harvest they
delivered thoughtfully sourced chef's
crafted food that is built on fruits and
vegetables and can be prepared in less
than five minutes fill your box with
more than 65 different options like
ready to blend smoothies refreshing
chilled soups and savory harvest balls
olive taling harvest ingredients are
sourced and selected for maximum
nourishment the best part tailee harvest
single serving cups are that ultimate
grab-and-go meal or snack so you can get
a dose of nourishing fruits and
vegetables at any time of day I find
he's particularly helpful
mostly for breakfast because who has
time for breakfast these days you fetch
you in your morning show when you're
more like a working woman but it's like
what you put into your body especially
in the morning like makes a difference
on how you feel like I've been eating
like garbage so I feel like garbage look
when I'm on my grind just like waking up
every morning with like my bowls like
that really makes me feel good
know as it should and now I like milk in
my fridge I never have milk in my fridge
for because it's a harvest when you put
you could put you can put ice or you can
put whatever you want but I put milk I'm
like I've groceries you know got now
got milk yes veg so go to jail harvest
calm and enter promo code toast to get
$25 off your first box that's promo code
toast for $25 off your first box at
daily harvest com daily harvest calm
code toast
that's daily harvest calm oh is it no
it's still a harvest a Compaq sweet
because they change their website ooh
exciting
anyways love daily harvest gives me the
energy I need to give you the first
story okay which is just a premium bit
of news you know it's not necessarily
business where's it from
it's from page six oh so it must be
about someone's super glamorous
super glamorous super famous beautiful
and thin yes I agree
Instagram star Claudia joy celebrates
song toast with the cast of southern
charm oh my god I can't believe my
party's in paid chicks like that that is
actually the tell-tale sign of a good
party yeah it is and I know we probably
would say this no matter how the okay it
really was but you need to call no no we
would say this no matter have the party
shake now because we love our friends
our family and like the greatest really
do but it really was the place to be in
New York last night you know like it was
the happening spot
we had Housewives reality stars models
singers pop stars comedians counselor
yes counselors
campers campers guests including Real
Housewives of New Jersey star Margot
Joseph's sipped on signature cocktails
including a spicy claw tarita while a
countdown to the singles release at
midnight played on a projector quote
southern charm stars Shep rose Craig
Conover Kathryn Dennis and Austin Kroll
also attended after filming the Bravo
show's season 6 reunion curls on-again
off-again Madison Lacroix who made
headlines when she accused Rose of
getting cast mate Danny bargain STD
which rose denied was also at the party
Danny bard was there I mean I've never
met her and I just don't know why I like
people I just like have this thing where
I assume people like Know Who I am like
especially like when you're at my party
yeah so I saw but like I do need to
check myself in general like I I saw
Kathryn I gave her a hug and she was
there with Danny and like I just gave
Danny like a huge hug I'm like let's
take a picture like I was being so
annoying but like and she 100% like I no
idea who I was and that's fair for Danny
she's never met us before she doesn't
know who's never met her okay so she's
never done a reunion then because every
time they have a reunion we go out with
them oh that's true it's like our annual
thing I only said it's three years in a
row it is good it's so funny it's like
every time I see it on my time hop I'm
like oh oh that was fun I've ever had
yeah totally but this time was bigger
and better than ever by the way Madison
the cry said something so cute well not
cute actually I was starting to her in
all sin and she was being like super
weird and shy and Austin was like
Madison thinks you don't like her and
I'm like what and honestly like I don't
you're like really like a southern charm
Stan like I just like dabble in and out
um did I say anything I said she's nice
I don't I don't recall I can't like
we've only said nice she hasn't really
been in the thick of it and
this week but I came up with a good
answer ready I'm like no you know what
it is it's like actually like was being
like such a [ __ ] stirrer I was like you
know I'm just like really a friend to
Shep and like I just like tell I do what
he tells me and like he just doesn't
like you so I just like listen to him
but that's how I was thinking about it
last night because I don't know it's
just I was talking to cast of so every
term in [ __ ] like I really love them all
so when it's good P it hurts me and I
really have so far been T Madison even
when chuck was here and he was
explaining why they aren't a fit I feel
like we're not being told the whole
story because based on everything
they're saying there's no reason why
everyone should be so invite us in in
awesome yeah you know so that's I just
feel like I don't know everything and
therefore until I have all the
information I really like Madison and I
like it so so cute look I'd love to see
was so cute she's like 30 times cuter
and person like the cuteness doesn't
emulate auntie she was so petite yeah
and I liked her relationship with
Kathryn and now we know she is a single
mom which makes more sense as to why her
and Austin might not be a fit because he
has to stop partying like if you're
gonna come home to her son and she just
like can't be flexible about that agreed
so I'm really enjoying her on the show
and even though what she said was like
definitely cross the line below the belt
about the stdm
she went toe to toe with Shep and I love
Shep but like you have to be able to you
know play the game play the game t-shirt
out as much as CDs specifically
chlamydia you will get chlamydia and die
so that was really crazy Anna she could
have said if she really wanted to like
do get him like I heard you gave a girl
chlamydia like shouldn't have to bring
Danny into it right but you know
hindsight's 20/20 No
so anyways this sound like a great party
and like for everyone that was there and
especially this girl and her big arms
taking a photo of the girl that's me by
the way she looks like look how big my
arms look I do have to tell you like I
did face to myself thus making you like
a little larger you oh really I didn't
think people would really see you like
you were in a sea of people but I now
realize that was selfish and I'm sorry
oh I don't care I'm just glad I don't
actually look like I don't know you
actually looked like super cute and
petite but like I needed to take some
inches off my waist
oh that's totally fine because it's
really not about me in this picture I'm
glad you agree yeah even though everyone
else is kind of faceless and I'm just
like no I mean you're really there yeah
you know I'm really
to page six his ability to really like
know what cool parties were torreón last
night yeah and to really just like get
the hard-hitting news and it really was
interest on I guess Madison and Austin
are together doesn't harm you mean we
were getting spoilers and I don't want
to spoil it for anyone but it's a it's
always lit but it sounded like a good
one yeah and they were all like looked
so exhausted like it was like a it was a
treacherous day for them yeah it was
treacherous safe for a lot of us but we
wouldn't want to be anywhere else maybe
there I had a big all day about this
night for a long time and honestly I
feel the party coming on should we go
back out no oh my god I need to get back
in bed like I have literally the worst
headache ever and my body is fatigued af
I understand you know that's Alyssa the
boxer man yeah get used to it need to
come up with some choreo you know oh I
was thinking that like smooths that we
could all do you know make it uh next
hoedown throwdown
we're like the next bad romance you know
Oh totally you know what I'll take the
lead on that because I am for good job
yeah cool
next story little boy we were like oh
time in your life when like you love
dancing like you wanted to be a Rockette
I didn't want to be a Rockette I've
always loved dancing but I you when
you're a kid like it's normal to like
take dance class and you took a really
seriously I took it really seriously
well we used to we took all the same
classes but I remember when I went to
camp yeah uh we took dance class and
then they made like an elite squad of
dancers and they made the team known as
the special dance and I made the team
which was like really crazy because I
had like no properties it's like being
on the gymnastics team when like you've
never had a coach like it was everything
and the coach of the special dancing you
was a former rocket was it former
Rockette so I was just like inspired by
her inspired so many people always ask
oh my god when I was in France I and we
were going all these clubs like I could
not stop dancing
this is Frenchmen like he was sitting
with his son and his wife and I I saw
them watching me dance and he came up to
me after and he was like in his French
accent he's like it is a joy to watch
you dance I was like I think that's a
nicest thing anyone's ever said to me I
think so too I think he's a dream it was
a dream for me to see joy for them
such a nice compliment yeah no one
literally ever said that to me or even
remotely like they're gonna be like you
get that and they would be that can you
stop I can't see that girl ID you know
but they're the things taking it on
stage and saying yeah they well now they
would yeah
I like your song could be big and like
Ibiza it's definitely like a club you
should send it to Paris I did did she
give you any feedback um um I just said
to church some weight I don't know just
listen to it yet but I did and I'm
really trying with the idea of having
her remix it if she would do it I would
be very grateful
honestly it would be a dream for the DJ
who does remix it because like we said
it really is a Bob it's Bob Susan over
here
okay next story Stassi Schroeder Bo
Clarke celebrate engagement with the
Vanderpump rules cast sassy and Beau are
engaged she got engaged in a cemetery
herzman and um like when I saw it on my
on my screen like I looked at it for
four seconds before I realized what it
was you know what it needs you it was an
interesting announcement low-key as hell
very that's what I was it's a very
low-key and I feel like she's so extra
um but I just love them I'm so happy for
them and when I think of like all the
people stassi's dated like I feel like I
know her because like I watched our show
every day since the beginning of time um
I'm just like I feel like I feel
complete like I've been on this journey
mm-hmm and I'm just so happy where she
landed also I feel like her and also
Naomi they had this like thing where
they just like don't think they're good
enough for these men that they're dating
yeah and I'm glad I hope now she can
like relax cuz yeah he's engaging you
don't have to like put on any more and
it's like everyone was moving into
houses but I think they want to get
engaged before it like now I wonder if
they're gonna live into a house but also
she had a nicer apartment than the rest
in the can yes but like when all your
friends have houses like you just want a
house yeah I do want to have sex every
day I just need a fire pit I mean like
burn make one in a trash can over her
raised beautiful yeah she's from bos
side of the family I think it's Beau's
grandma I feel like that's so her to
have like a vintage ring and like not
you know she's very into that oh my god
I didn't realize that that is really
cool and I mean the most interesting
factoid about
engagement was beautiful they went to
Lisa Vanderpump's house christened Dodie
was nowhere to be found
Stassi doesn't follow Kristen on
Instagram anymore and I've heard that a
bunch of this season is Kristen having
falling having a falling out with Stassi
I'm Katie
that makes me upset because Kristen took
the chance like she was the one who
brought Stassi back into the fold and
it's like I finally came around on
Kristen when four seasons I was like
don't be friends with her and now
they're good friends with her when I
want them to be friends no I am like so
100% a Kristen Jodie supporter she's
literally never not been anything but so
[ __ ] nice to me I love her so much
she's a good time
so I'm saddened by this and at first I
thought maybe Lisa Vanderpump was just
being an absolute [ __ ] not letting
Kristen into her house because of their
history for sure but now it looks like
Stassi didn't invite her not Lisa yeah
and even if Kristen couldn't be invited
she might have just posted that Congrats
to my friends where maybe she hasn't say
she had like something she had to go to
like jury duty she still would have
posted congrats to my friends there's
something amiss but I'm really curious
about the timeline of the season because
I feel like they would normally end with
the wedding but it's a bit Jackson
Britney got married then Tom and Katie
and now an engagement where do you think
the season ends um in a few weeks or
maybe with this engagement
yeah but the party at me says yeah but
they usually film longer look actually
but they started earlier because of the
wedding okay you know yeah so it will be
a great season that means we'll get it
earlier hopefully yeah so many sim
clothes for the Vanderpump rules family
so many sim cuz they're all really
figuring it out except like now with
every season that's like a wedding it's
kind of annoying how they're like
staggering I don't want to watch a
wedding every season that's so I don't
want to watch an engagement every season
I'm gonna meet my bridesmaids every
season Lala and Randall they are getting
married off camera yeah they have a date
though they do yeah I love them love
them I love how much he loves the banner
public kids like he's like living his
dream can you see the trailer for the
Irishman no it's the new Martin Scorsese
movie with like everyone and Randall is
somehow involved in it um and it's gonna
be like the next big thing it's on
Netflix oh it's gonna be honestly I'm so
happy I hope it does well I went low I
just have a happy full life full of lots
of nice things full of lots of nice
things I agree and there was a new cast
mate yes oh my god she looks great and
you she looks super huge she's friendly
with
Lala and Ariana I saw them yeah I speak
he was a great teacher he was premium as
[ __ ] and I start trying to him she's
really cute great I'm excited okay third
story
Megan Marco launched a fashion line with
designer pal
Misha no new with a surprise twist for
every article of clothing bought a piece
will be donated to Megan Marcos royal
patronage smart works Megan Marco is
adding clothing designer to her resume
in the September of an issue of British
Vogue which she guest edited the
Dutchess of Sussex revealed she is
partnering with her designer friend
Misha no new to create a capsule
collection of women's work where the
line which will be which will be
released in September it will benefit
her patronage smart works a charity that
helps women land jobs that's so nice
that is nice make it murder was just
doing it all do you see the vogue thing
no like British Vogue it's um they
interviewed like 10 of the most powerful
people in like in the UK and they were
all interviewed by Megan mark all
injuries for the people who were part it
was so top secret I saw like someone who
was a part of it like they literally
couldn't tell their husband that I get
mark Electra read them they should be
able to tell their husband it's like you
don't trust her husband yeah what you
keep what else you keeping from him it's
cool I didn't know she was a journalist
and I've been thinking a lot about Megan
Marco because also she's at that like
rich people conference the Google thing
yeah where it's like there's they all
got together to talk about climate
change and they all took over over a
hundred and forty private jets landed
and like polluted the earth
look engages carpool like could have a
carpool also how would they not know
what that people would roast them for
that no a Nazi this such a lack of
awareness yeah but okay so I'm sorry I
was some pictures of her and I just like
I really that moment in particular like
really put into perspective for me like
how my game Marco is just like literally
getting everything she's ever wanted
literally she's getting everything any
human being has ever wanted knows people
she probably couldn't actually she
probably could but most people don't
even dream that big I'm just like I want
a house with a fire pit yes mansion on a
hill yeah yeah I'd like to be you know a
world leader I only want to mansion on a
hill if the memories will keep me
company
yeah whenever you're alone yeah after
all of your running I'm finally coming
home I think I'll do a ballad next
you think oh yes so what's next for you
I honestly want to do a cover like
release a highly produced cover
something of brave yeah I was gonna do
shallow look when I was in the studio I
actually like was supposed to record it
but I feel like the time has passed like
everyone's over shallow agreed agreed
and everyone's doing covers of shallow -
are they yeah like Danielle Bradbery and
like whatever sweet ham snitch with the
shade yeah totally murder what are your
thoughts on Danielle Bradbery
there we interviewed her she's very good
do you kind of like her song I like her
selection red wine on a white couch
there's a great song ready and you would
know how I discovered it I was on a
flight to LA listening to one of your
guys's playlist and I fell asleep and
with my ear pods in and then this song
started playing in like I had my body
literally woke up because I wanted to
write down the song and it was sway Oh
makes you wanna sway to the left and
sway you want to hear the most annoying
thing yeah I fell asleep on the plane
yesterday with my air pods in and one of
them fell out never to be seen again
what yeah I got down on like my knees
after the fight ended like with my
flashlight I couldn't find it one time
most recently I left the the holder so I
had the pods but you can buy a holder oh
you can it's like still expensive but
let's also buy one ear pod I I can get
my air pod your air that's where we got
our air pods
snitch like walking past the Apple store
that's where we got o pods
she also has a thing I'll Bradbury
another good song potential and yeah
diary and literally a military and like
ever like mmm do not buy our very
doesn't do it for me how many good songs
you know hurt herself doesn't do for me
because she's very quiet and like an
underwhelming yeah that's fair she's so
small to say so fro so crazy
totally what were we talking about Oh
dreaming big Megan Marco living the
dream
I know it's like I I don't I don't find
that I dream too big all I want to sweet
em one on iTunes and have clear skin and
honestly I'm on my way to doing both
thanks to bio clarity I is a clean and
green skincare brand that has products
that just work what healthy eating does
for your body bio clarity does for your
face their skincare line offers easy to
use routines with good for you
ingredients that will give you great
skin
I found out it without bio clarity from
a very influential Instagrammer Margaux
wash right and your skin really was
looking so good and I asked you and you
said you were using bio clarity and it
really makes a lot of sense because if
you go to a drugstore and you like look
at face washes like the amount of
chemicals it's really disgusting it's
not good and that's that's something you
should be putting on your face and when
you look at the bio clarity stuff it's
like brown and green cuz it's like
organic it's from the earth that's what
it should look like yeah and my face I'm
Courtney - my makeup last night and she
said my skin is so much better
that's amazing yeah I'm excited about it
you can get healthier more radiant skin
by going to bio clarity comm and right
now for our listeners you will save 40%
off on skincare routines plus an
additional 15% off everything on their
website it's an incredible deal but you
need to enter our code toast at checkout
so go to bio clarity calm and get 40% of
skincare routines plus an additional 15%
off everything on their website when you
use our code toast at checkout that's by
clarity comm code toast love it what do
you guys think about the song the archer
oh did we not talk about it
well you I'm sure you did but I'm just
curious I spoke about it with Margo
because my first initial reaction I was
like getting really frustrated by the
song because the beat never drops and
who actually looked at like the wave
progression of the song like where a
normal beat would drops she doesn't the
song progresses evenly and then at the
end it drops a little it was like
frustrating me because if they had the
kygo could turn that [ __ ] into a [ __ ]
banger but I guess it was all about the
message of like having anxiety like and
and like but it was it was like a
metaphor that the beat didn't drop yeah
it really I mean it's a great song it
really reminds me of like kind of like
an 80s like Pat Benatar you know we're
in the car necessary and Ben thought Pat
Benatar his name was Pat Benatar kept
saying now I'm like Ben at all he's like
no it's not that's funny he's gonna play
music on his phone he's gonna listen to
some Pat Benatar and I was like what did
you just say that's hilarious
it's a good song what do you think about
it I really like it yeah it's giving me
like you know fearless guy this is me
hope it's giving me hope and then I
really like the lyrics are great she's
not over producing it and it gave me
hope like she's still the girl that we
all wants to the lyrics are beautiful
and I really like it a song and no it's
not a banger but it's not meant to be
yeah it's just a well done song
all my heroes died alone oh my god that
never leave me darlin but that it's like
the epitome that lyric is like a like
that's like my life like I am so overly
confident about also being incredibly
self-conscious like who would ever leave
me but they would say yeah
so that is lyric that I just really like
resonated with personally yeah okay
interesting now for a little business by
the way like when we have our daytime
talk show and we do like the business
segment and you know they'll put like a
title card up and I'll be like a cute
graphic of us being like business
planning for the future sane and since
we are apparently influencers in the
fake meat market I believe you two are
the faces of impossible burger and
Beyond burger - well that's what this is
about
I would be remiss if I didn't let you
know that beyond me competitor
impossible foods plans to launch in
grocery stars in September after getting
FDA approval you Mikey Minden sound so
glamorous I want to go shop at a grocery
store yeah it's beautiful
yes great name for a chain that is
thanks our webshop
yeah it's a grocery star yeah and it's
in Hollywood
someone fund our project beyond meets
rival impossible foods plans to start
selling its vegan burger in grocery
stores in September the FDA has approved
impossible foods use of soy lega mo
blabbin as a color additive earlier
Wednesday impossible announced a
manufacturing deal with a major meat
supplier you know what this is I'm just
so happy for the whole I'm really
possible time I'm so happy for you guys
like this just means you can like make
when there's a barbecue and you guys
aren't eating like you just say hey
throw my impossible burger on the grill
yeah and people like might think it's
cool it's not like a veggie burger that
like falls apart you know like the peas
and carrots falling through the grill
yeah however I will say when it comes to
at home like that's where I have all the
options and it's when I go out where I
need impossible options like Burger King
having an opossum burger is just so
pertinent if everything's recently
announced that they're gonna take it
nationwide I guess the test markets did
very well yeah so every it would be
great if every fast-food McDonald's when
he's had impossible options therefore I
could like eat more than just french
fries because when I'm home like there
are a lot of veggie burgers that I
didn't have pushing me in your house
yeah where I can order from a closed
restaurant all right so I had a coastal
steak before my party last night they
really felt like he gave me that energy
to survive like the night it was a long
night that's great a filet mignon I
really treated myself we deserve it
before the shards where's Margo going I
think she's walking out she can't take
it anymore
oh she's working on something she's
Shilpi a project by the way she um she
just quit I don't know she just like
walked out I think they're doing a
walkout oh my god totally for Greenpeace
okay fifth and final story in news that
is pertinent to the situation organizers
finally cancelled troubled wood sack 50
fester oh yeah this was a long time
coming and I just think it's for the
best
organizers announced Wednesday the
troubled festival that had a series of
setbacks in last four months won't take
place next month oh my god the screen of
the snitch can empty dead the three-day
festival was originally scheduled for
August 16th through 18th but holdups
included permit denials and the loss of
a financial partner and a production
company last week jay-z dad and company
and John Fogerty announced that they
wouldn't perform at the event after
organizers said it was moving to
Maryland from New York this thing was
just riddled with problems and while it
would have been cool to honor you know
the legacy of Woodstock I just think
like if these days people are so
sensitive to like things going wrong at
festivals because we as a generation
we've been scarred we have PTSD so I
just think this is really for the best
you know I don't think people I don't
think there should be there should be
rural there shouldn't be there shouldn't
it shouldn't be allowed to have like so
many new festivals every year do you
know what I mean it's dangerous no
here's the rule you shouldn't be allowed
to sell tickets to something until the
infrastructure is up and running 1,000%
and there should be a company a festival
like the FDA for vegetables words like
you cannot have a website until we come
and check out your grounds yeah we're
like see or do an audit yeah because
they won't have the festival up and
running but we need to see your plans
your blueprints how are people gonna
take a piss yeah there needs to be a
festival Union yeah Noah festival like
the FDA the Federal Drug Administration
yeah the festival the festival
I'm trying to think of a word for the
day but yeah it's not coming to my
custom illustrations sure stitch
everything okay yeah no I was just
working on something there's gonna be
loud so you're back to work now yes I
was working overnight we were we were
actually like you know interviewing
people yeah we thought there was a
walkout yeah we missed you we're so glad
you're back you're so tan thank you
anyways I'm feeling proud of the
Woodstock organizers for putting their
tail between their legs and not like
ruining people's weekends with their
crap yeah my weekends are so precious to
me these days it's like all I want to do
is be at home be with vo be with Ben and
just not be bothered like if I'm if not
only if I'm paying but if I'm leaving my
house to go to something new organized
and I don't feel safe or there's not
enough food or there's no bathrooms or
in the case of fire festival like there
is no festival um that's something I
take really seriously no I agree which
is funny because you call me this
morning like trying to organize so we
can't rehearse yeah all you want to do
is stay home yeah I think we should say
I'm down I was thinking that but I would
have gone with you did you know what it
was is I stayed home last weekend and I
was so bored because you weren't here
Margo like was in a mood but she like
Larry wouldn't talk to me on FaceTime
Olivia I saw the deans act three times
only people what that's hilarious
what was everything okay counts yes I
came out my friend yes she was being
like a kid and like I was like her mom
and she like literally wouldn't [ __ ]
answer my phone and I was like laying in
bed like so bored looking for some human
contact and my girl wouldn't give it to
me maybe we're not really bad we should
check our 23andme you should because you
sometimes act like a sister and then
sometimes you don't know I think it's
key you should check your 23andme 23
meat is really really interesting
because there's a whole world of genes
just waiting to meet you and 125 plus
personalized genetic reports on your
health traits and more the right
personal health plan starts with the
right data your health reports can give
you insight about your DNA so you can
build a health plan that's as unique as
you it's important to understand your
genetic predisposition to certain health
conditions like type 2 diabetes it can
be impacted by hundreds of genes other
things can play a role too like
lifestyle and family
Street it's just so crazy that we like
live in a world now where it's like you
can just like not even go to a doctor
like from your home find out everything
about your body and like how to take
care of it and live forever yeah you
know hopefully hopefully God willing
23andme reports do not diagnose diseases
or describe overall likelihood of
developing any disease 23andme tests
selected genetic variants only visit
23andme dot-com / toast for important
test information order your health and
ancestry kit at 23 let's numbers two
three and me.com slash toast and you can
meet your genes in 125 plus personalized
genomic reports that's the number two
three and me.com
slash toast love it it's just it feels
good to be back you know like that it
feels back back in the groove it feels
great to be back honestly I really
missed everyone everyone here everyone
at home I really missed the toast and
the toasters how to Lou but I made a
recall of that Margaret Nora made this
weekend Claudia was like a little sister
being like hanging out with your
mother's I know I'm hanging with my
friends yeah too cool for school that
counselor snitch your friends do when
you hang out drink well I liked when you
said that word I literally just got um
did you recap or Honi no we didn't know
but it's on it was the part three oh it
was over ya know then we didn't um but I
did finish it how did it end I'm getting
so confused between Beverly Hills in New
York I haven't watched Beverly Hills so
it was an excellent camille Grammer had
a top-five walk-off really yeah because
she got naked oh my gosh I have to see
but also so I read Howard Stern's book
and then I watched his movie private
parts and camille Grammer John itachi is
in it and it was fire well yes it was
filmed in the 90s so it was before she
was grammar so she was just a girl in a
bikini and I just didn't know if that
was public knowledge or not but she says
hi I'm Camille and this is Howard goes
to Michigan or whatever and her bathing
suit in the snow so I just feel like if
people didn't know that they needed to
know important to know but watch me
Union let me know what you think it
ended like on a nice
besides for Camille she was being so
crazy like it really the New York
reunion ended on a good note I thought
um the LuAnn I'm at all like still
here's what was bothers me about LuAnn
like the last episode was really about
her you know and herd evenness in her
cabaret whatever and she saw herself
doing this to Bethenny like when Shumlin
said that we did talk about this already
there's no way that we did cuz I just
watched it yesterday okay yeah so when
she did this to Bethenny and she's like
queen bee and then she like saw that
that was wrong and so when everyone's
doing their regrets she like regrets
that when it's like you missed the point
no she's so like she's so shallow but
she's trying to prove that she's not
know it's like they asked her what she
thinks about what she just saw and she
was like and so could you can you blame
me for what else it could it be if not
jealousy and then like everyone tells
her no this is what you just saw this is
what you should feel and by the end she
just says that but it's like her initial
reaction to the clip shows how she
actually feels about everything yes
she's not good at I mean and this is the
key to being a good housewife is having
a huge lack of self-awareness which is
why I could never be a housewife I'm Way
too self-aware yeah I agree
just so many TV shows are like coming to
an end yeah but then we're coming to a
start with Ossie and Alice Oh Dallas
Dallas looks good I saw a posting the
toasters that a girl set next to DeAndre
on a flight and they like she like
talked about the show the whole time and
DeAndre was so nice oh my god he's like
did you hear that I love Dan George oh
I'm excited and I hope she doesn't have
to make too many dancers choices no but
that's the thing about being a Real
Housewives of Dallas it's it's chock
full of D address choices yeah so and
LeAnn's getting married oh yeah it'll be
interesting great and carries no longer
on the show I know oh I saw some shady
stuff because people are saying that her
and Marc um left the show because
there's like a huge potential of them
getting their own show and then it's in
the works or whatever and Brandie
replied to a tweet it was like no no she
was like oh I didn't know that Congrats
but no but she was like I think she also
said it was a youtube serious I think it
is a youtube series I don't know that
there's huge potential for a show for
them to get there I actually like them
and I wouldn't watch her show know
we have botched yeah we're good yeah
like we're good I've just really been
daydreaming about this night for a long
time wow I just I've been daydreaming
about this guy to get back on the show I
just really like we really I have a
really new that we only digit one I have
an invigorated low that's where the
shins are for yeah no but I never
expected I never expected for me to be
the person who would like go on vacation
and like miss working no that was a real
shock to the system because as
entrepreneurs who like absolutely love
our job like it's not shocking no it was
really crazy I learned so much about
myself I want to play the song for
everyone because I've actually been
waiting for this day my whole life just
want to really reiterate you guys the
song is available on Spotify iTunes and
pretty much anywhere you can get music
iTunes preferred so I can climb that
chart but you know do what you got to do
I really I think she's a quick break and
cleared his head so we can dance what do
you think likes to do okay I'm like so
hungover but it'll take okay put the
title card up and we'll be back to dance
to my own song and then we'll be gone
but just once they love you miss you
can't wait to be back so we are here to
your preferred I got a email today
I got my email today too but I saw a
bunch of people already got their
packages so that's really exciting tag
us I want to see that flag Frank what am
I going to see on the back of a book fly
diving the boat back of the truck
flagpole toasters you know what's up all
right we're gonna put the title card up
in the back in a minute
you
I'm counting town until we start wearing
a gates we come to play yeah we play
hard honey tell me you're gonna have a
good time a thousand hands up to the sky
we gonna toast to tonight
what it even feel like feeling it all
day I wanna let it go
I wanna lose control oh I'm ready to
roll
and I've been changing man about this
night for a long time
shake it if you know it you let's go
girls
I chose to the WHA one's toasted hips I
chose to the lovers a toast to you and a
toasted allowance you and to you and I
okay the speakers but our spirits do not
so stream toast by toast we have our
summers and it's [ __ ] late everyone
have a great weekend send me videos of
you singing toast in your toast merch we
love you so much have a great weekend
you